Les Oscars d'accord, nous devons donc aller à un cosinus
tel qu'un ici et qu'est-ce que vous
voulez, ils attendent West au
lieu de notation de la bibliothèque si vous voulez, c'est très
proche d pour le samedi après
tout, je dois positionner ce que
j'ai  c'est sur la carte d'accord c'est je commente
oh juste un autre cadeau il y a de l'autre
côté ouais c'est exactement qui chose
j'espère que le temps est ouais nous aide
mais elle très je vous avec c'est le haut
nous ne pouvons pas cacher ce que nous devons tourner
notre ça  aux héritiers vous aidera à sortir
pour apprendre une nouvelle soupe celle d'une
femme difficile nous ne sommes pas de l'huile éthérique palatucci super drôle
pour contrôler le handicap DC
qui concerne l'homme de race d'accord oui
encore une fois déjà
nous sommes très très très proches de l'échantillon
en disant oui mais les nuages oh le temps
change si vite ouais hé il y a beauc
up de vent là-bas il y a le telus 20 nœud
20 pas seulement là où on est l'espace en desso
s ouais où on veut tirer donc on va
bien et tu n'  t av
les coordonnées de la pla  ce oui oui je l'
ai où nous ne pouvons pas
croiser
ici qu'ils peuvent venir une filles illusoires
ils veulent que je le fasse encore oui s'il vous plaît
mot de passe cela signifie-t-il que c'était
des inscriptions conservatrices solides et bien rien
en retour Oh mieux ou suis-je trop
politiquement
c'était ce que tu fais âme pédante il est
tellement énervé contre un bon chemin de plaisir
que je me demande ce qu'il est bien content de rester
là c'est bien
tu peux monter juste un autre niveau de bouchée
ou juste